oh happy day President Trump announces
that he will not fund the government
unless he gets funding for his wall or
actually as he is now putting it his
artistically designed steel slats we
will examine whether a wall by any other
name is just as big and beautiful then
President Trump announces he will
withdraw US troops from Syria a move
that has drawn deep division between
conservatives and a military veteran in
the US has started a GoFundMe page to
build the wall ourselves and this thing
is increasing by millions of dollars
every hour we will monitor it I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
Oh oh you thought with it we're only a
few days until Christmas you thought it
was all over no way Jose
president Trump the king of reality TV
had a few more tricks up his sleeve
there is a major showdown shut down
fight brewing the headline from CNN
right now is is are you ruining my life
Republican senators in disbelief over
Trump shut down threat but I'm not in
disbelief I'm happy I was you know I was
a little worried there for a second you
know yesterday was a little worried the
president Trump was gonna cave in but he
apparently has not so we'll be
monitoring that first let's make a
little money honey with candid CO oh you
know candid candid is helping people
gain confidence for accessible and
affordable orthodontic care candid makes
the process of straightening your teeth
convenient and easy by having the
customer take the process into their own
hands you get straighter and brighter
teeth in an average of six months and it
costs sixty five percent less than
braces and you won't need to have all
that you know gross gear and stuff in
your mouth and not be able to ask girls
on dates and seventh grade is that I'm
just reliving my own childhood
experience but candid Co makes it so
much easier it uses orthodontists with
other other aligner companies may use
dentists or dental professionals but
candid uses real orthodontists it makes
clear aligners that are sent directly to
your home they're customized
specifically you straighten your teeth
your teeth the modeling kit retails for
ninety five bucks
provides you a 3d preview of what your
treatment will look like candidates
treatment time is an average of six
months and it will literally save you
thousands of dollars compared to the
other guys you remember this it used to
be really expensive candid comb makes it
easier one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candidates risk-free modeling kit
guarantee when you use my dedicated link
candid co.com slash cough fasc o fe fe
fe you'll save 25% on your modeling kit
that's candida co.com / co f f/a co v fe
fe e to get 25% off the price of your
modeling kit candid koat.com / cove fa
oh happy days so I just want to rewind
for a second you remember yesterday we
were talking about how President Trump
he was going to cave he wasn't going to
shut down the government he was missing
his only opportunity to get the border
through Democrats were so happy they
were they were so happy that Nancy
Pelosi went to a bar last night with all
of her Democrat friends and danced along
you just have to see the clip to believe
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so for those of you who are only
listening you can see Nancy Pelosi right
there staring up at these aging white
liberals singing off-key and playing
acoustic guitar surrounded by other
aging white liberals swaying and dancing
back and forth she's a bar she's dancing
by the way if I made a computer robot
watch a thousand hours of Aging white
liberals just being themselves that is
what it would come up with as the
Platonic perfect version of aging white
liberals being themselves
just playing kind of schlocky 60s 70s
music on acoustic guitar singing out of
tune everyone's kind of out of shape
they all still think they're cool
they're trying desperately to be cool
that's the definition of white liberal
baby boomers is they just can never not
be the cool guys so it's oh man she
thought she had it she was so excited
President Trump he was just kind of this
perfunctory meeting today with House
Republicans at the White House then
they're gonna get the continuing
resolution they're gonna keep funding
the government until February 8th right
is that what happened Paul Ryan we just
had a very long productive meeting with
the president the president formas that
he will not sign the bill that came up
from the Senate last evening because of
his legitimate concern for border
security so what we're going to do is go
back to the house and work with our
members we want to keep the government
open but we also want to see an
agreement that protects the border we
have with very serious concerns about
securing our border the president said
they will not sign this bill so we're
going to go back and work on adding the
border security to this also keeping the
government open because we do want to
see an agreement
oh don't tell me christmas came early
it's only the 20th christmas isn't
supposed to happen for five days I told
you all I want for Christmas is five
billion dollars in a big big beautiful
wall and Paul Ryan is announcing this
that President Trump is delivering we
should have seen it coming because
yesterday you know I'm broadly quite
supportive of the administration I think
they've done excellent work they've been
so much better than a lot of people
expected they would I was really upset
yesterday and I was not alone in this
Ann Coulter tweeted out or she was
she was talking she was on a podcast at
the Daily Caller and she said that
President Trump if he didn't get the
wall his presidency would be a joke
there would be no reason to support him
she was pretty brutal toward him she was
so brutal that President Trump actually
unfollowed her on Twitter apparently
there's a Twitter bot that monitors the
the Trump family accounts and who
they're following he actually unfollowed
an and I wrote you know Ann Coulter has
been pretty tough on Trump the whole
time and she's been tough on him in a
way to push him to do better to push him
to not alienate his base to push him so
that he doesn't lose in 2020 and I think
she's tried to maintain this tension
where she wants to really really push
him but not so much that he'll unfollow
her so he did unfollow her but then he
listened to her as well I mean you know
we were pretty tough on him in this show
yesterday at the same time that the
signature campaign promise
you're basically caving in and not
delivering on you choose instead to free
thousands of prisoners from the clink
through this first step Act prison
reform bill it's just a horrible moment
I mean just a really low point for the
Trump presidency especially as the
economy starts tanking so I I don't know
what it was exactly who was whispering
in his ear but today he totally turns
around and he says that we are going to
do it and he says he's going to build
the wall in a very specific way he sent
out this tweet and wrote the Democrats
who know steel slats parenthesis wall
are necessary for border security are
putting politics over country what they
are just beginning to realize is that I
will not sign any of their legislation
including infrastructure unless it has
perfect border security USA wins now
you'll notice in that tweet the wall is
in parentheses and the new phrases steel
slats steel slats okay so what what do
we mean by steel slats well you've
probably seen the rid of a number of
prototypes of this wall one of them is
that it slides up and down and
conservatives are a little upset about
this I think the left is actually trying
to pretend conservatives are more upset
about the steel slats versus the wall
than they really are because but what do
I I don't care what the wall looks like
I don't care if it's got graffiti all
over it I don't care if it's made of
steel or marble or concrete or whatever
I just want the thing to be built
president rabe also went on he tweeted
quote when I begrudgingly signed the
omnibus bill
I was promised the wall and border
security by leadership would be done by
the end of year now it didn't happen we
foolishly fight for border security for
other countries but not for our beloved
USA not good
absolutely right this is totally right
and so the left is trying to still
portrayed this as a retreat they're
saying well okay he's going to shut down
the government they're furious about
that they thought they had a bead on
that so they said well he's gonna shut
down the government he's not even gonna
deliver the wall
he's foolishly recklessly trying to
rebrand it his steel slats who wants
steel slats Maggie Haberman who was a
total in the tank for Hillary Clinton
the Clinton campaign sent emails about
how they could rely on Maggie Haberman
of the New York Times to give them good
coverage he or she is on CNN trying to
portray this as some Republican loss the
goalposts have moved right I mean he he
realizes there is not going to be a
concrete wall so he has to start
rebranding it for his followers to look
as if he is the one who created this and
this was not wasted upon him and again
that will work with some some of his
supporters it will work with some of his
base the problem is is that you can't
constantly try to wave away your
previous statements and assume that
nobody is watching
there is a weight to these there is a
certain collection of them over time
again his his supporters mark meadows
and Colter didn't do him any favors but
they didn't do him any favors because
they know where his voters are but
they're reminding people that this
really was the last chance if he was
serious about getting this wall you
don't sign this continuing resolution to
keep the government funded through
February 8th so Maggie Haberman is right
about a couple things here she made
those comments in fairness to her before
it became clear that President Trump was
willing to shut down this government to
get his border funding at the very last
minute and so I think she would probably
modify her comments now so she's right
that this is the last chance and Ann
Coulter was right about that mark
meadows and president Trump realizes
that what she's wrong about is she says
that President Trump keeps changing his
language it's going to be a big wall
it's going to be 10 feet higher Mexico
is going to
we're only get Mexico's gonna pay for it
indirectly because of a new trade deal
because of increased this or that or the
other thing it's gonna be a wall now
it's gonna be steel slats and so she's
she's trying to say that when you make a
promise it is stuck in time you can't
change you can't negotiate it has wait
which is true except for this
administration
it doesn't President Trump openly says
this he says I am having the art of the
deal I am always negotiating I'm gonna
ask for five times more than what I
really want so that I can whittle it
down and just get what I actually naming
for so know if he says I want a big
beautiful concrete wall and then he says
okay okay I'll settle for steals lads
steel slats is the wall I really see no
difference here and I think this may
actually be a sort of clumsy strategy
from President Trump so that it actually
gives Democrats a little bit of an
opening if they want to vote for it
because Democrats should vote for border
security Democrats want to get reelected
just as much as anybody and the majority
of Americans want a structure along our
southern border not just Republicans not
just independents Democrats too they
want the wall the majority of Americans
want the wall so Democrats are
answerable to that they were all for
border security at least in their
rhetoric until a few years ago when they
became beholden to the far left of their
party okay so he says well you don't
need to vote for the whole wall you can
vote for steel slats I'm kind of into
this steel slats I am I the only
conservative who sort of prefers
artistically designed steel slats to a
big concrete wall you know it it I do
have to remind myself sometimes
conservatives you know we're Philistines
we don't like artistic things we don't
like aesthetics we don't don't take any
of that into account we disregard the
culture but the founder of modern
conservative philosophy Edmund Burke was
actually an aesthetic philosopher he
wrote a famous inquiry into the origins
of the sublime and the beautiful
thirty-three years before he wrote the
founding tract of conservative political
thought modern conservative political
thought so I actually kind of like the
idea you know
slats I don't know they let in more
light they're probably a little more
pleasing on the eyes that I like the
idea of the steel rather than the
concrete the concrete has a little bit
of a Berlin Wallisch vibe it probably
won't age very well one nice thing about
the steel slats is they can extend all
the way into the ocean but actually our
own casi Dylan went down to the border
and she interviewed a Border Patrol
agent down there and the Border Patrol
agent made a good case for the steel
slats over the concrete wall in 2017 six
companies were given 30 days to build
prototypes for president Trump's
proposed 30 foot tall border wall which
would replace the steel mesh barrier
each prototype cost four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars but a finalist
has still not been chosen you can see
they're all different we did a testing
and an evaluation process which took
about 60 days what did the testing
include the testing included anti
scaling anti climbing imagine scaling
that you could see it's 30 feet tall
very intimidating yep in 2017 funding
was secured to replace the Vietnam era
barrier with an 18-foot tall see-through
fence made of steel posts and anti
climbing plates this modern fencing
extends all the way into the ocean and
so what's the benefit to the new
see-through border compared to this one
we have no idea what's on this outside
if I'm being assaulted if I am you know
patrolling an area and there's a group
forming eight to ten people I want to
know and I want to be able to see what's
going on this I think is the best
argument for the steel slats over the
wall because look this this isn't it
isn't like President Trump said okay
well it's politically impossible to get
a giant concrete wall so I'm gonna get a
giant steel wall with some spaces in the
every so often and that's much more
politically feasible to get or less
expensive or something that's not how it
works
they're both difficult to get
politically it's difficult to wrangle
Democrats it's there's not much of a
difference between the two I think the
best argument is that people are going
to continue to try to come into our
country illegally that's not gonna stop
and so they can either try to hurl
things over a big concrete wall or
they're gonna try to hurl things over
the steel they steal slats and also just
doesn't matter of being intimidating
those slats kind of seem a little
scarier to me because they're kind of
like spiky you can imagine trying to
scale the slats and like impaling
yourself I don't know I'm having very
dark visions about the whole thing but
it's really for the protection of our
border security we're still going to
need a lot of agents down there on the
border monitoring this there gonna be a
lot of people trying to get guns and
drugs through and so it's it's probably
as that Border Patrol agent says to
their benefit to be able to at least see
what's coming to see how many people are
on the other side to see what kind of
danger is being presented and also it
allows it to extend into the ocean I
suppose they could extend it into the
ocean anyway just using the slats that
way and then they could have concrete
for the rest of it though the one
worried with the slats is that people
would be able to pass things through it
so drugs or guns or whatever again
probably that wouldn't be very effective
because we can still monitor via drones
we can still monitor via video cameras
so we could probably apprehend people
one way to do it though is to just have
two sets of steel slats so you're
building two structures but pretty close
to one another maybe fill it with a moat
and some alligators in the middle such
that you wouldn't be able to pass things
through that's easily solved though so
I'm all for it I say build the slats
build the slats that's gonna be our new
chant and I've just anecdotally I've
convert to conservatives about this and
say do you or do you really do prefer
the wall to the slat so this last the
wall they don't care just build it
protect the border
get it through this is the time to do it
I am glad that President Trump is
doubling down I mean tactically speaking
now he actually has some leverage
because he let them think that they were
gonna get it through and they all made
their plans for how to start the new
year their christmas plans whatever he's
actually in a better position now so
it's entirely possible that he was
letting this fester the whole time that
he was sort of leading them on and
lulling them into a state of complacency
and now he's doubling down it's also
plausible that he saw the reaction from
his followers and from his voters and
his supporters and he said likes if I'm
losing Ann Coulter if I'm losing the
Michael Nolt show which is like named
after a typo that President Trump
you know I mean the the co FFA thing is
the title of my F tour I'm pretty
supportive of this guy if he loses me on
an issue like that
then maybe they've got to double down
and I'm just so thrilled I'm actually
you'll notice I'm not in the studio
today I'm down in Palm Beach I'm down
the road from the winter white house I'm
actually going to an event at mar-a-lago
tonight so I'm sure there will be lots
of good gossip maybe I'll be able to
bring some to you tomorrow
but this is great I mean this is this is
what we came for Russell Crowe in the
gladiator are you not entertained
is this not why you were here this is
the stuff we should never have doubted
that the reality TV guy would give us a
great season-ending cliffhanger to go
into 2019 a really really good stuff and
again this is such a winning issue for
Republicans there is actually a GoFundMe
now that was started by an American
military veteran who said we're just if
you're not gonna fund the wall Democrats
we're gonna fund the wall ourselves and
this let me just check what it's up to
right now when I checked this this
morning I don't know what's up four
million dollars or something it's now at
seven point three million dollars that's
been raised by a hundred and twenty
thousand people over the course of three
days the idea being if all the people
who voted for Donald Trump contributed
that's about 63 million people if they
contributed what 80 bucks you'd fund the
wool five billion dollars the the goal
right now is a billion dollars on this
on this GoFundMe campaign and I think
this is great by the way I think it's a
really good idea this guy's name is
Brian Cole fij he's a Purple Heart
recipient a military veteran triple
amputee and he says look I've given a
lot for my country I'm deeply invested
in the future of my country I don't want
to have given all of that for nothing so
we got to build the wall and protect our
Liberty and protect our sovereignty
protect the integrity of our nation and
you should help me out to do this now
what he said is he's working with a
legal team they will make sure that
every dollar that is donated can only be
used legally by the government to build
the wall and if they only fund it
halfway then they'll try to strike a
deal with the government to fund it the
other half of the way
and if they don't make a deal if they
can't fund the wall with this money if
they fall short of any of their goals
they're just gonna refund the money I
think this is great I think this is
terrific some left wingers are making
fun of conservatives for this they're
making fun of them and saying what what
a bunch of dupes they're giving their
money and paying extra taxes some
cynical conservatives are saying that
too I think it's great I think it's
sending a terrific message to people and
to the President and to members of
Congress in the Senate
to say we want this wall we want it so
bad we want to protect our country so
much we're willing to put our own money
on the line about this a hundred twenty
thousand people in just a few days and
the number keeps rising I keep
refreshing the page and you just see
more and more people a thousand people
since I last refreshed it a few minutes
ago have donated money to this I think
it's great and I think that these
Republican senators some of the squishy
ones I think their jaws hit the floor
this from CNN Republican senator Susan
Collins almost dropped her handbag
Thursday as she gesture disbelief at
word delivered to her by reporters that
Donald Trump would not sign the budget
extension to keep the government funded
until February unless border wall money
was added did he just say that she asked
as she left a Republican lunch ah are
you ruining my life no you're doing your
job you're being forced to do your job
because you weren't doing your job
because neither Republicans nor
Democrats have ever really cared about
stopping illegal immigration and funding
border security none of them really have
it's this unholy alliance made between
these open borders left wingers and open
borders chamber of commerce wall street
journal type Republicans love the
journal but it's that kind of
perspective that says oh well they
shouldn't do it but sure love that cheap
labor oh well they shouldn't do it but
gosh it's pretty good for the economy
and we'll get to why it's good for the
economy in yeah well we'll get to it
right now as a matter of fact which is
that there was this study that came out
which showed that the least educated
state in America do you know what it is
the least educated state in America I
know you're thinking Mississippi Alabama
haha those down the southerners
California that's the least educated
state in the country and of course I
believe that I'm surrounded by
Californians all the time
so with California and then number two
is Texas Texas is still a pretty red
state then it's New York
then it's New Mexico then it cuts to
goes to Kentucky Nevada Arizona I
thought how is this why is it the bluest
of the blue states than the reddest of
the red states then the blue again New
York and why why are these the least
educated we're always told New Yorkers
are so educated and sophisticated we're
always told that Californians are so
educated so sophisticated so why is that
what's going on then I looked at the
percentage of illegal aliens living in
these states and it turns out they match
very well they don't match one to one
but greatest percentage of illegal
aliens is California with in the top
five you get Arizona you get New York
you get all of these Nevada has a lot so
it's not a perfect one-to-one there are
other factors as well but this is a big
one this makes perfect sense you're
talking about people who are flooding
into the country without much of an
education I don't begrudge them they
come from bad countries and they're
coming to America because America is a
good country but when you have that
unchecked when you just allow people to
flood over completely unvetted without
any limiting principle then there are
negative effects on your society
education levels go way way down wages
especially at the low end of the wage
spectrum go way way down this affects a
lot of people it might not affect the
people writing for the New York Times
but it does affect a lot of Americans
and what underlies this immigration
debate what actually is underlying the
immigration debate the reason why the
Wall Street Journal wants illegal aliens
to pour into the country is that the
u.s. population has grown so slowly in
the past year it's been its slowest rate
in over eight decades the growth in the
south and the west is outpacing people
in the Northeast and the Midwest but
this is all according to new figures
from the Census Bureau people are not
having kids in the United States they're
not replacing themselves u.s. life
expectancy has decreased now two years
in a row at least that's for the first
time in 50 years
why because of suicide because of drug
addiction we are living demonstrably on
every single measurement in a very
decadent
culture that is losing vitality doesn't
have much vitality at all and the way to
artificially prop up those cultures is
to flood it with migrants from countries
that are not decadent yet
that's what's that is what's underlying
this is a a loss of American vitality or
a sense of purpose or determination or
at least in certain parts of the country
and so you try to prop it up this is
what Europe has been trying to do for
years Europe is you know just a couple
decades ahead of us on this they've been
trying to take their dying populations
and resuscitate them with Muslim
migrants coming from the Middle East and
that has negative effects because
they're coming from different cultures
and they're not being made to assimilate
and it just takes a while to to bring
people into society and if you have a
multicultural ideological regime they're
just not going to come in they're just
not going to come in at all so I hope
that this stand this this moment this
president president Trump's moment the
cough FA the exuberance the the new
sense of American hope the idea that
maybe we have a few more good days ahead
of us maybe we can fix problems maybe we
can take wages which have stagnated for
10 years and increase real wages
maybe we can manufacture things everyone
told us we can't manufacture anymore
maybe we can everyone told us we can't
stop illegal immigration
maybe we can everyone told us we just
have to fight wars of empire that
monitor the entire world as a sort of
benevolent patriarchy maybe we can be
our own country too I mean this is what
underlies president Trump's bit major
announcement today that he's going to
withdraw troops from Syria and this is
this is causing a lot of consternation
this is a big debate on the right here
as president Trump's announcement we've
been fighting for a long time in Syria
I've been president for almost two years
and we've really stepped it up and we
have won against Isis we've beaten them
and we've beaten them badly we've taken
back the land and now it's time for our
troops to come back home I get very
saddened when I have to write letters or
call parents or wives or husbands of
soldiers who have been killed fighting
for our country it's a great honor
we cherish them
but it's heartbreaking there's no
question about it it's heartbreaking
now we've won it's time to come back
they're getting ready you're gonna see
him soon these are great American heroes
this was another major announcement it
totally blindsided people a lot of
Republicans are not happy about this the
one leading the charge Marco Rubio came
out against this move a lot of them were
I don't I don't want to call them
neo-cons but certainly the
neoconservative types the more
establishment foreign policy
conservative types are coming out
strongly against this Lindsey Graham is
leading the charge this to me is an
Obama like decision I hope I'm wrong
but I don't think I am and I have no
understanding of why we're doing this to
me it is an ill-conceived idea
the downside is really great and the
upside is pretty small all right so the
warnings are dire that Russia and Iran
and Hezbollah those guys are all
celebrating today and Assad too
what do you make of it one of my
colleagues just called this an Obama
like decision I couldn't disagree more
and I couldn't agree more with the
president's decision look by definition
this is the opposite of an Obama
decision Obama got us involved trumps
taken us out Congress has never declared
war or authorized the use of military
force in Syria we shouldn't be there
anyway without Congress doing that so
that there at the end that was a
Republican Senator Michael Lee who comes
from the more I don't know civil liberty
minded wing of the Republican Party and
the conservative movement and he is
applauding it Rand Paul is applauding
the move as well this is a this is a
long-standing debate among conservatives
the more call them isolationist strain
and the more wilsonian strain
interventionist go around the world
police the world I would say my take on
this is probably unsatisfying to both of
those which is I don't think it really
matters that much if we pull out we only
have 2,000 troops right now in Syria
those troops are basically helping
Kurdish forces and protecting Kurdish
forces a bit
we have lost servicemembers in Syria
it's very hard to get precise numbers on
this but I think that number is about
five American servicemen who have been
killed in combat in Syria one
servicemen killed is a terrible thing
compared to the losses in Iraq and
Afghanistan obviously it's it's very
minimal the reason again that I don't
think this withdraw is the the huge end
of the world that Lindsey Graham is
making it out to be is we still have 57
or 5200 troops in Iraq for those of you
who are a little geographically
challenged Iraq is right next to Syria
so if we did have a strategic interest
if we did have something we wanted to do
in Syria we could easily deploy those
troops there right there I think there's
a symbolism to taking the troops home
because the question that the people who
wanted to pull the troops out have asked
is what is our strategic goal in Syria
what are we after what we're being told
now is if we pull our troops out then
the Syrian butcher President Bashar
Assad will be strengthened of Russia's
role in the region will be strengthened
Turkey's role in the region will be
strengthened maybe I guess what is our
strategic goal do we want to remove
Bashar Assad from power I'm not sure
about that I don't know but there's
Bashar Assad is one of the worst people
on earth but who would replace him would
it be any better would we just have
chaos would we further empower Islamist
rebels I don't know with the good guys
went with the bad guys win I don't see
and and they won't even articulate the
strategic interest it seems to me the
strategic interest is in being there to
monitor to maintain the status quo to
not let any one power be it Russia a
foreign power or Bashar Assad a domestic
power gain too much control as this long
game of chess and geopolitics maybe it
is that why can't we do that from Iraq
why do we have to do that with troops on
the ground in Syria do we really think
2,000 troops on the ground is going to
do a whole lot in Syria it's going to
tip a civil war that we're not even sure
which side we're fighting on of course
and I just don't think it's a huge deal
and it is president Trump fulfilling a
campaign promise and he's got to fulfill
those campaign promises because he's
facing reelection in 2020 and Americans
broadly not just right-wingers but left
wingers to get war fatigue after a while
and unless you can articulate a
strategic objective there and the reason
why it's so essential that we have 2000
forces to
two thousand troops in Syria I just
don't see the interest okay we've got a
lot of mailbag to get to but first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go to daily wire.com it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you'll get me you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Indra Clavin
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag coming up you get to ask
questions in the conversation you can
test questions in backstage you get
another Kingdom which is now been
finished for the second season and I got
to tell you guys it's really good I can
comment on that because I contributed
nothing to the writing of it and the
story is so good I mean it don't tell
drew I said that but it's excellent so
go over to Daley wire.com give us all of
your money and we will be right back
with the mailbag
I'm gonna burn through this mailbag
today I'm getting to all of them from
Joel hi Michael I'm a big fan I was
hoping to get your opinion on a
statement I heard recently to understand
racism you need to understand power
dynamics to understand sexism you need
to understand power dynamics to
understand poverty you need to
understand power dynamics to understand
power dynamics you need to listen and
believe the stories of the powerless
okay so my opinion on that statement is
it's not very insightful or profound at
all what that statement really means is
shut up that's what it means I know it
doesn't quite sound like that at the
beginning it's okay to understand racism
you need to understand power dynamics
well that's not quite true but I but
certainly power dynamics have something
to do with racism okay to understand
sexism of power well yeah okay maybe
poverty well yeah I mean you need to
understand economics and human nature
and in labor markets joke a well but
then they come in and they say you need
to listen and listen and believe the
stories of the powerless when they say
listen they don't mean listen like you
and I mean listen they mean stop talking
so you need to stop talking and then
believe the stories of the powerless no
I'll believe the stories of the credible
I'll believe stories of people who are
telling things that are worthy of belief
they don't just believe anybody Wow
anybody can lie a rich guy can lie a
poor guy can lie of rich guys have
interests poor guys have interest and
then of the powerless nobody is
powerless in America nobody is powerless
a four-year-old orphan out on the street
with drug-addicted abusive parents even
that kid is not powerless in America he
at least has communities and he has
certainly the state to come in and get
him out of those bad situations a lot of
charities to help people
nobody is powerless in America so just
the premise there is this very Marxist
premise that there we have these class
struggles between the oppressor and the
oppressed and that's
that define then the oppressors which by
which they really just means straight
white guys who think that they're guys
they need to shut up and the everyone
else gets to talk and tell them what to
do that's ridiculous
of course that's not the case people who
have good ideas should be listened to
and we should always be listening to
everybody but then we should use our
judgment and our reason to determine
what is true and what is good and
beautiful and what is false and a bad
idea I'm gonna lead us down a bad path
from Justin
oh great knowledgable my ex and I broke
up over a year ago and have not really
communicated since looking back I see
all of my previous shortfalls and have
noted that the breakup was most likely
caused by our immaturity as individuals
and as a couple
she really was everything I wanted in a
wife she's the only girl I've said those
three little words to should I send the
text to my ex if not how should I go
about meeting new people Justin
PS I thought about sending this question
to mr. Shapiro as well however my ex
listens to his show as she listens to
his show huh yeah that's well she she
doesn't listen to my show she clearly
has very questionable judgment you
should delete her number from your phone
and move on get a girl who has better
taste in podcasts listen you're asking
me this question because you want
permission to do something right
everything you're telling me is saying I
want to text my ex she is perfect we
were both immature we both made mistakes
I really loved her
that's the only girl I ever said I loved
can I text her and if you're asking me
permission yeah sure I married my
ex-girlfriend you know I've mentioned
I've talked about this before sweet
little Lisa and I were highschool
sweethearts
we split for college we got back
together my life is great my life
couldn't possibly be better everything
worked out wonderfully I'm all for
texting your ex if it's the right thing
to do don't text the wrong ex if they're
if the reasons that you broke up were if
you broke up because I don't know
immaturity you know you she was moving
somewhere or you were going somewhere
you know whatever that's fine I had one
guy write into the show and say that his
his girlfriend kept cheating on him and
kissing other boys in front of him and
breaking up with him
yeah dump that girl don't text that girl
but you know people change people mature
if you really like her if you've gone
out you've kind of played the field you
talk to other people and you you like
this girl more ya texture that's great
I'm all for it but don't do it because
you don't have anything better to do
I mean don't do it because you're afraid
of going out there and meeting someone
new do it because you really love this
girl and if it's the latter go do it and
if it's be if it's that you're just sort
of settling for her because you're
afraid to go meet a new girl you don't
know how to meet a new girl go to a bar
buddy you go meet a new girl there's a
there's a lot of fish out there but I'm
I'm offered texting your ex and marrying
your ex I hope it works out for you from
Richard dear Michael how do you think
your bestseller packed with factual data
and indisputable arguments will hold
against Clapp Shapps new book look I
mean work like reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide is a a
once-in-a-generation work of genius and
not ever not everything can be compared
to that book I mean how could you
possibly with such economy of words with
such brevity and therefore wit be able
to convey such an incisive a message as
I conveyed in my magnum opus reasons to
vote for Democrats I would never hold
been to that standard you know I mean
been for one been uses words in his
books so I I just don't know how he
could convey with such concision and
precision the sort of things that I did
but I did read Ben's book and it's a
very good book I really really enjoyed
it so I'm sure it'll sell you know a
handful of copies but you know again
since it's not really just cutting
through right to the soul of the reader
you know I obviously I don't know that
it'll do nearly as well I think my
prediction is it will be the second
best-selling and most important book of
the last two years that's how I think
it'll do and you should read it it's a
very good book from coal do you have any
advice for compelling for constructing a
compelling argument against abortion on
a scientific level most people I talk to
won't acknowledge the moral dilemma that
abortion presents thanks coal let me ask
you a question can you can
strucked a compelling argument against
murder on a scientific level on a
scientific level so we're talking about
the physical we're not talking about the
metaphysical or the moral or the ethical
we're just talking about on a physical
on a meat level
why shouldn't you murder somebody
because you'll get blood on your
clothing I don't know can you construct
for me a scientific argument against
burglary or a scientific argument
against rape know if anything if we're
talking about science then we know that
we have a biological imperative to
spread our genes so there's certainly no
scientific argument against rape there's
really a scientific argument for rape
although not really because again you
can't make scientific arguments about
moral questions these questions all of
these things really everything that
matters to us in our in our lives that
we consider really eternal questions is
a methyl or a philosophical or a
metaphysical question it's not a
physical question so of course you can't
do it there's no scientific argument
against abortion there aren't really
scientific arguments period when we
argue we're talking about ideas and
ideas are not scientific I can't I can't
take an idea and look at it under a
microscope an idea is out there and
ideas are enacted by physical processes
and and that you can study
scientifically but you can't study the
idea the reason that abortion is wrong
is because it's wrong to take a human
life without due process certainly we
know that it's a human
we know that it's alive we know that
it's individual what or what argument
could you make to end that life without
due process I can't find one find me
that argument you can only make moral
arguments and if people won't
acknowledge moral dilemmas then I guess
they can't make any other argument
either but I suspect they do make other
arguments they just don't want to face
the reality of abortion from Sally hi
Michael have you ever noticed the
linguistic link between being observant
in a religious sense and the actual
meaning of the word being watchful
I don't think Millennials have been
encouraged to look deeper into
themselves or deeper at the world it
shows in their amoral politics how do we
bring religion into the conversation
where it is
consequential than the next Instagram ad
thanks Sally
a great observation pun I suppose
intended we constantly see that this
isn't just the Millennials who are being
oblivious to this this is even true of
religious people sometimes sometimes
religious people will say well I said I
believe in Jesus and I'm saved I believe
in you and now I'm saved that's okay I
don't need to think anymore
this contradicts both the letter and the
spirit of the New Testament we know in
the Old Testament we know in Genesis sin
crouches at your door it desires to have
you but you must take control over it
it's there it's crouching it's not
sitting
it's crouching it's ready to pounce on
you we know from Peter he writes a be
sober be vigilant because your adversary
the devil as a roaring lion walketh
about seeking whom he may devour he's
constantly we know we see it all
throughout the Gospels they say be
vigilant stay awake why can't you stay
awake endure until the end it's not easy
to endure until the end but you should
there's a prayer in the Catholic Church
that they used to say at the end of Mass
all the time and then it became
unpopular for a while in the 60s and 70s
when the church became much more kumbaya
and saccharine and sentimental and now
it's coming back a little bit because we
realized the reality and personification
of evil and it's the st. Michael prayer
the prayer is very quick it says st.
Michael the Archangel defend us in
battle be our defense against the
wickedness and snares of the devil
may God rebuke him we humbly pray and do
Thou O Prince of the heavenly host by
the power of God thrust into hell Satan
and all the evil spirits who prowl the
world seeking the ruin of souls who just
listen to that language there it's
prowling sin is always there for us
we've got to constantly be watchful of
that and I hope some of these self-help
guys who have become popular say that
you know they speak to a very
Aristotelian sense which is that virtue
is a habit you form habits and that is
your virtue the more you do you the more
you practice the virtues the the more
natural they will feel the better you
will be at them and if you're in a state
of habitual sin
sort of addiction or whatever then your
your it's very difficult to break out of
that Christ says the man who sins is a
slave to sin and you've got to
constantly be vigilant about that but
it's not just those Millennials I think
that's a lesson that all of society
could take from Jason what do you make
of Jordan Peterson's nonsensical word
salad whenever asked directly about the
Incarnation or the resurrection of Jesus
you know I couldn't possibly say you'll
have to ask Jordan himself about his
answer to questions on the Incarnation I
have asked him this directly before I
think we did it on the air a little
while ago I also want to make the point
though because I hear this sometimes
from the religious right and from left
wingers they'll criticize Jordan
Peterson the religious right we'll do it
because he's he's a Jungian basically so
he's only speaking about metaphors and
he's very he gives a vague answers on
questions like the Incarnation and then
the left doesn't like him because he's
getting people to take seriously
traditional concepts and religion though
both of those sides are saying that
Jordan is doing more harm than good I
think it's pretty clear that he's doing
more good than harm I've talked to a lot
of people who are religious people who
will they reverted or converted to their
faith because of Jordan Peterson and
it's because what Jordan Peterson does
so well is he exposes the frivolous
shallowness of modern materialism of
modern atheism how low their arguments
are how what a what a ridiculous and
silly view of the world that they have
and he exposes that because he's talking
about mythology he's talking about
mythology and he's talking about
symbolism and he's talking about the
Bible and I really hope that someday
I'll be able to sit Jordan down as I've
tried many times and get him to follow
the logical conclusions of those ideas
as I see them but if Jordan is getting
people to do that to follow the logical
conclusions of these ideas and come to a
true faith what he's doing God's work on
earth it's great stuff I'll take one
more
dear lively I have two questions okay I
guess I'll take two more with the latter
involving an anecdote
what is your favorite Protestant
denomination and - I made the mistake of
mentioning I heard Lutheranism described
as Catholic light to a Lutheran pastor
he calmly explained to me why Lutheran's
are the true Catholics and the Pope is
the Antichrist with a great deal of
citations I don't remember is there any
validity to these claims I'll take the
second one first no there is not any
validity to those claims a good book on
this though on the history of the of the
Reformation and specifically Luther is
how the Reformation happened by Hilaire
Belloc and so that's a good book it's a
short book and I think it will give you
a flavor of why that that individual was
confused as for my favorite Protestant
denomination I've got to go with the
Church of England of course I've got to
go with High Church Anglican which is
basically the Catholic Church except
they don't like the Pope twice the
liturgy half the guilt as they describe
it and this is because Henry the 8th
when he broke the Church of England away
from the Catholic Church he didn't do so
for theological reasons he remained as
basically a Catholic until the day he
died he did it for political reasons be
asleep or swipe and the Pope was being
stubborn about that but also political
reasons in that he had to maintain his
line of succession he had to maintain
certain alliances but Henry the 8th was
given the title by the Pope of a
defender of the faith he wrote a
beautiful
IRRI beautifully about the sacraments
and the Catholic faith so I really like
that unfortunately now the Church of
England is sort of an empty husk it has
all of the gilding or it has all of the
you know ornaments of the Catholic
Church but it's been basically hollowed
out from the inside but I still like it
I still go into Protestant churches of
Anglican churches sometimes and it's
nice to hear especially these days the a
lot of the Catholic liturgy is so awful
that the if you go to the Anglican
Church you can figure out what it was
supposed to sound like that's my
favorite one I actually take a lot from
Protestants though I always like to
Alvin Plantinga the Calvinists of
analytical philosopher at Notre Dame and
I always enjoyed Tim Keller
years ago I would listen to him a lot
more so there are some good ones out
there too all right that's a
surprisingly ecumenical end to our show
we will be back tomorrow I got to go
boogie tomorrow Lago and figure out
what's going on with this government
shutdown but I'll be in town also for
the TP USA student action summit so if
you're around I look forward to seeing
you tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael an old show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018